now where to begin
my mother named me anola
[Music]
which backwards spells alone
and yet we were always together
congratulations on anola holmes it is
awesome so exciting lots of girl power
and this girl power spin on sherlock
holmes so
why was this a project that you felt
like you had to be a part of bringing to
the screen
i think that um the shoutout home story
is very um
it's revolved around men and that's
always nice
but um this story is very much
uh surrounded by women and it's
definitely women-centric which i think
is very important especially in a time
like this
um i always wanted a young
british female lead to look up to and a
nola is that for me
a nola is that from my seven-year-old
sister as well so that's really exciting
to have her
have someone to look up to and to relate
to um
this story was meant for the screen um
you know i loved it
in a book but i'm very much of a visual
person and nancy springer told this
story in a book
so i needed to tell this story a week
ago on screen
and i needed to deliver and uh this
story was meant
it was meant for the movie screens and
for people to watch you did so well in
this and louie you too i can't sell you
short man because you were her
your side her sidekick and partner in
crime i'm vice campbell chuck springer a
useless boy
you have to help me i'm not ready to die
on a train i'm not ready to die at all
and i wasn't going to before i met you
what do you hope fans take away from
this film louie
well yeah continue continuing on from
what millie said i think it's
so important that these stories are told
you know with this fresh
new lease of life like who wants to hear
the same story over and over again
but i mean it's it's i think it's great
from a female perspective but also from
from from my character playing somebody
with long hair who's really into his
flowers who's
really gentle and you know i i quite
like that you know
stereotypes for everybody and for men
you know sort of got to be you know a
man you know
which it really isn't and i love that um
i love that nolan troops we have this
sort of reversal i think it's really
really
powerful i love that you said that nelly
this is not a world that's all too
foreign to you because you are very good
at solving mysteries on screen
i mean from stranger things so low so in
real life though
how do you how are you at sloo thing and
solving and cracking cases in real life
i'm
terrible um yeah no i am not very good
at that
um you know i i leave that up to my
family they're very good at kind of
solving things i usually am the one that
predicts very wrong um
so yeah anole is very smart in that
respect
she's very strategic and she's um
very observant and intuitive and i think
that that's what makes her
you know a very detective but i'm not
that
um i'm very observant and i can see
through people and
you know i can see transparency very
quickly in a person
louie i gotta ask you you guys get into
some trouble in this
movie so what was it like working
opposite miss milly over here
it was great there was never a dull
moment that's for sure
we had a great time like the whole shoot
was just energetic and fun
i remember the the the very first day
that i walked into i opened my trailer
and on my mirror midi had written in
makeup like in in
a lipstick that she took from the from
the makeup trainer
happy first day cheeks i reckon i kind
of
set the tone for the rest of the shoot
i'd say so
i must become something
unexpected
a lady really you yourself you had to
hop into a little bit of a
like a variety of roles and in one scene
you're
a widow and another scene you are a posh
english woman another one a male
gardener so did you enjoy taking on the
different costumes for
portraying those types of characters in
the film as well absolutely i think that
manola touches on masculinity and and
you know more
feminine looks which i think is very
much needed and she's ending gender
norms
which i love in this film and uh yeah
look that you had maybe i mean i love
the sherlock look i love the hat
and the you know braces i didn't know
that
that for me did it i loved it um but
obviously the scene where she's
a lady i love that because it really
it um shows that she can be
who she wants to be she can't describe
herself but the widow outfit
is kind of iconic i mean when i walked
on the set i felt like the queen of
england i was like don't talk to me
and my husband died you know i was
literally i felt very
empowered we had an amazing costume
designer constellata
who put lots of detail and thought into
our characters at our costume
[Music]
you as pumped as fans are for season
four of stranger things because we are
so excited of course we know that
production was shut down due to covet
but you know when are you guys getting
back to work have you heard any word and
what can you tease for the fans
um we have not but what i do know is
netflix is
incredibly um protective of all of their
shows especially
um us young kids so um
we will get back to work when they know
um
you know when they know it's a safe
environment for us to all to work in so
we i have not had word yet
but what i do know is it is very very
very good
wait and then i'm sure have you been in
touch with david harper because of
course big news coming from him he just
got married to lily allen
you know he deserves um endless
happiness and
i i'm they're a very cute couple so i'm
with them
the best and i love them both i love the
pictures from their wedding it was
so fun you know kind of iconic so in the
spirit of vanilla homes
we have our own cipher for you guys to
figure out
are you a game let's do it all right
you ready louie here we go let me give
you a clue well you definitely know
one of the three words because you know
yeah
the title of the film one of the the
lead characters
and i will say the abbreviation for
entertainment tonight is in here as well
[Music]
wait you were very close louie did that
mean i might not be
any good at songs but i can do art
bt hearts alola
[Music]
he gave it to me i give that to louis
partridge
very very dreamwork
exactly very good to us i feel like
there are
more and nola homes films in the making
could this be possible is this a one and
done type film
or will there be more in the future
um well as everyone knows this is a book
series so there's definitely more
stories to be told and the nola's story
hasn't fully
finished yet so we would love a green
light on something like that
um it would be it would be very special
to work together with
you know everyone again so i would love
nothing more
[Music]